- [Voiceover] Use the rotation tool
to determine the angle of rotation
about the point (2, -3)
that will map line segments HE and RO
onto the other line segments.
So, we wanna rotate HE,
this is segment HE,
and this is line segment RO,
and we wanna rotate it around this point
so that they map, so that their images
after the rotation map to these two
right over here.
Let's think about it:
which one should map to which?
So, it looks like HE
should map to this right over here.
Well, actually, let me just play around.
I can add a rotation.
I could add a rotation here,
and let's see, I could rotate around.
If this point over here is going to,
well, we already know we're gonna
rotate around the point (2, -3),
so let me write that.
We're gonna rotate
around the point (2, -3),
and let's see, if we rotate by 90 degrees,
what happens?
That was too much.
Oh, actually that's too little,
because a positive angle right over here,
we're going counter-clockwise
by 90 degrees,
so Point R mapped to this point
right over here, Point O mapped
to this point over here,
but we want it to go even farther.
We want it to map to maybe this point
over here, so let me increase this.
I don't know, let me try 135.
All right, it looks
like we're almost there.
Maybe let's try 140.
Press "Enter."
That still didn't get us there.
Let me see 145.
We're getting close, maybe 150.
150, and that looks pretty good.
It looks like we have done it.
So, if you start with these,
the set of points that represent
line segments HE and RO,
if you rotate them about the point (2, -3)
by 150 degrees, and the convention is
that that's going to be counter-clockwise,
we see that we map, their images
are going to be these two lines
right over here, and we saw that
Point O right over here maps
to this point right over here.
Point R maps to this point.
Point E is going to map
to that point, I believe.
Yup, that's right, and then Point H
is going to map to that point,
and obviously all of
these points in between,
for example, this point right over here
that's on the line, that would map
to halfway between these two segments
right over there, so there we have it.
We've done it.